this is the theme the deegeu bismillah
alhamdulillah Salam alaikum peace be
unto you this is a very special episode
of the Deen show we're here in Texas
that's right y'all with a live studio
audience
and we're gonna get everybody involved
you can get involved from your house you
can get involved with your family sit
around the TV and enjoy this week's show
because we have a special guest David
gulley on who comes from a background of
Baptist missionaries fifty years in the
making
he accepted Islam and he's here to tell
us his story on the Deen show we'll be
right back
this is the thesis betangel
this is the Athenian Jew misses the
enjoy
mr. David Goggin gully and i'ma start
off with pieces we do as Muslims
somebody come alaikum Salam peace be
with you how are you sir playing a
hundred on now I'm very honored to have
you on our show thank you now we we get
a lot of special guests like yourself
people you know we interview from all
walks of life you know you you seem like
someone you know when you look at you
you know somebody who's just a an
American and people are looking like man
is this the FBI or something yes or you
know the chemistry teacher you just you
know somebody from from outside look at
it it's like man this is not a Muslim
you know because they think Muslim you
know Arab Pakistani what happened here
basically when I came to the point that
I investigated Islam I felt that based
on what I knew I was forced or compelled
to become Muslim by the sword no simply
forced to become Muslim because it was
the correct religion or the right belief
okay so tell us a little bit about your
history you heard me mention in the
beginning that 50 years of Baptist
missionaries yes my parents were there
now about disease they were Baptist
missionaries in the Philippines for 50
years my father was a soldier in the US
Army in World War two and following the
Second World War he went back even as a
young person I came to realize that
there was a difference between the Jesus
of faith and what must have been the
person of history and it wasn't until I
began investigating Islam that I began
to make sense of who Jesus was and doing
this investigating a say using a Bible I
eventually became Muslim yes what year
was a set this was in March of 96 96
right and what happened was doctor all
I'm invited me to
talk to him and abu-bakr mosque here in
Houston and I went and I really wasn't
that interested it's like the only
question I asked during the whole time
that he was there that I was talking to
him or they were visiting with him was I
asked him says his prophet Muhammad the
Prophet as you would find in you know
the Bible and he said yes well in my
opinion I didn't think you know that he
was but I was going to investigate
because now I had all that I needed to
make an investigation so I I simply went
home got out my Old Testament they ran
down the different proofs listen the Old
Testament as to what defines a prophet
as they are defined in the Old Testament
then I went out to make an investigation
of Prophet Mohammed and to my great
surprise he fit the criteria then I was
interested I had my attention I got two
translations of the Quran and over a
two-week period I read both of them I
read one translation and the other one
and I felt a strong compulsion you know
become a Muslim but I did not want to
become a Muslim I said to myself I can
find just one good reason not to become
a Muslim I will not become a Muslim and
so I spent three months trying to find
some good reason not to become a Muslim
but based on what I know I felt that I
had to become a Muslim and so that's why
I'm a Muslim you get sometimes people
reacting in a way like when you tell
them you're Muslim what kind of
responses do you get to say come on you
kidding me just know quite often they
might think that it's unusual they think
it's unusual to be a Muslim that is
simply tell them that essentially what
islam teaches and what all the prophets
taught was make God central to your life
and then you either show where you prove
it by taking care of your fellow human
being and if you say for instance check
out the Gospels in the New Testament
you'll see that essentially and wherever
your different portions that you look
she just told people to love God fear
God obey God add them all together they
mean they essentially add up to
making God's central to your life and
and then you are to show or prove that
this is so but while you're taking care
of your fellow creature and Islam does
the same thing if you go to the mosque
listen to the Amman and see if he
essentially what hit the message that he
gives you know Friday after Friday as
may god central to life and take care of
fellow creature why do you think this is
usually when we explain this on without
even saying Islam well we explained the
tenants of Islam that Islam called you
to worship none but the Creator to set
up no partners with him only like you
said make that the central key point and
all your worship only God and to believe
in all the messengers of God and the day
of judgment accountability and to
establish a good character in your life
to do good you know people are like they
can relate to this but as soon as you
put Islam in front of it there's a
problem why do you why do you think this
is it's simply because I would because
they would associate the word Islam is
something being different or foreign but
in effect the word simply ultimately
means submission to God which is what
Christianity and say Judaism teach was
that you should submit to God tell us
what would you do how would your
response be we've seen something in the
media you know you're coming out of a
mosque or Masjid or an event and you
know a family gathering and then outside
of the mosque you had someone holding a
sign saying go back home
how would you respond to this if I go
back home I go to Houston cuz Houston's
my home I was born here in Texas so if I
go back home that's where I go back home
yeah and submission to God is a
universal message so wherever person
lives or creature lives that's their
home
yeah and in other words submission to
God is something that should be done
regardless of where person is how's your
relationship with Jesus now as opposed
to then if you read the New Testament
and you simply don't know what's going
on you find a character who you believed
intended good but is very mixed up that
would be the view of Jesus now now with
Islam
you can then understand what Jesus was
about which was essentially he believed
that it was his role from God to show
Israel how to be the example for the
world to follow and submission to God
and take care of care of the fellow
creature and eventually when he felt
that he was rejected by Israel if you
check say for instance Matthew 21:43 he
told
the leaders of you know Jewish community
that kingdom of God would be taken from
them and given to another nation or our
community that would in fact do what
they were told to do and then for
instance if you check John you see that
there was to come a comforter who would
be a perfect guide a lot of Christians
for instance I might say that this
refers to God the Holy Spirit but then
again if you take the same source you
see that this comforter had to be told
what to do others he didn't speak of
himself he spoke about someone else told
him in other words it could hardly be a
god he doesn't know what to say or has
to have someone tell him what to say
you've written a book called the last
Christian yes what's this book primarily
focus on okay it it isn't the theme that
it is involved in is trying to
differentiate the Jesus of history the
person who actually walked the earth and
the Jesus of faith
the first half the book is largely
concerned we're trying to explore how
the Jesus of faith came to be the second
half is trying to put together Jesus of
history the book is called the last
Christian because Jesus the historical
character you know it's not the same as
the Jesus of faith so in that sense he's
a Christian also problem you have in
trying to reconstruct a historical Jesus
is you can find indications or you can
find things that indicate what the
historical character was but very often
you can say well I know I got something
here but it's hard for me to say how
firm it is so it'd be much like you're
building a structure or a house where
say well I know I got a piece of straw
here this piece of wood I even think I
have a board here and that's a in that
sense Jesus les Christian because you
can't completely reconstruct the
historical Jesus now what you do find is
that all the indications of the
historical Jesus do not conform with the
Jesus of faith you know amazing we're
gonna we're gonna take a break and then
we're gonna take some questions from our
live audience when we come back okay
we'll be right back here with more here
in the den show
and with good deeds will find that good
reads clear out remind in your heart
of hatred and preconceived notions
racism and nationalism because you
cannot have anything inside of you
that's like that against people and
still be successful welcome back to the
Deen show and we're here with the author
of the last Christian David mr. David
thank you again for being with us we're
gonna go ahead we're here in Texas y'all
and we're gonna go ahead and get some
questions from the live studio audience
here in the DC on follow me
all right it's not the Oprah whole show
this is the gene show and we have our
brother with jaw head please step up
here's got a question for David yes
David salamualikum' within the 50 years
as I hear you have extensive history in
regards to speaking to people about God
in the message of God how did that
differ whenever you embraced Islam is
very rare that we actually see Muslims
go into places and you know knocking on
people's doors or kind of doing the sort
of kind of evangelical work let's say do
you find that it's a bit different now
to talk about God or the format and not
necessarily going to the people maybe
like you had in the past how did that
change how do you deal with that now a
big difference if you're gonna be like a
Christian missionary or preacher and
that's that sort of thing when you talk
about God you're primarily talking to
people because you want to get them into
heaven because you want them to believe
in the divine sacrifice God's divine son
when you're talking to people in Islam
you're trying to tell them the message
of all the prophets which is also the
message of Jesus that they should make
God's central to her life and they
should so
or prove it by taking care of the fellow
human being and you would then when you
talk about Islam you simply tell them
that essentially what you have in Islam
is you have a tried and proven living
community that has done just that that
has a record of how to do that
and that is what you speak about me
speak about Islam thank you
we're gonna go move on to the next
question young young young brother
please come up step up here and go ahead
and ask you a question to David go ahead
alright welcome I heard there is an Old
Testament recording that says to tell to
be able to distinguish a true prophet
and a false prophet and the a false
prophet or will be one who tells false
prophecies they prophesize about
something that doesn't come true now so
we have this issue or this conflict of
the teachings of Paul and Jesus Christ
peace be upon him what are some of the
prophecies of Paul and did they come
true
okay essentially and sometime during
Jesus's time on earth his ministry he
came to the conclusion that Israel was
not going to accept him as their Messiah
and he then said according to st.
Matthew 21:43 that God's kingdom would
be taken from Israel and would be given
to another nation or another community
that in fact would do what they're told
to do now Paul who would either was
either who was a Jewish scholar or
partisan or zealot this didn't go down
very well with them according to the
record as one finds it in the New
Testament he first was a persecutor
people who followed Jesus then he had a
nervous breakdown and after his nervous
breakdown he said that Jesus came to him
in a series of visions and dreams and he
told them you know his message and you
find that in this message you have a
different Jesus from all the indications
of Jesus who actually walked the earth
now Paul the thing remember about Paul
is that Paul said everything he taught
or preached or believed or said or did
came from Jesus now in two occasions for
example book of 1st Corinthians chapter
7 Paul tells the people that Jesus is
time when he's gonna be coming back is
so short there's a matter that if they
rejoice don't rejoice Mary Mary or don't
Mary buyers or don't buy it doesn't
matter now this is 1900 years ago this
didn't happen you'll find in the 4th
chapter of first Thessalonians that he
was telling his audience the people from
Thessaly that before everybody there was
dead jesus was coming back this didn't
happen now remember he said that Jesus
told him everything I would happen in
the future and Paul certainly at some
time during his lifetime believed that
Jesus was God so Paul was saying that
God told him this and that it didn't
happen so either you should believe God
told him this or that is Paul making a
mistake and where this is a test of a
prophet as you'll find in Deuteronomy
chapter 18 it says that a prophet if
he's if he speaks in the name of God and
he tells you something's going to happen
doesn't happen it's a it's a false
prophet giving a false prophecy and
don't listen to him here in Texas thank
you very much and we're gonna go to the
next we have time for one more question
young man young man please come up and
ask you a question so now when it comes
to long wait hold on before you start
see we're in Texas I haven't heard
nobody say y'all how you doing No
yes you mentioned earlier that some
people may see throughout your your time
as a Muslim that people have seen Islam
to be foreign what are some things that
you think that practices that Muslims
Muslims can undergo in order to
eliminate that or
what did you think through your
lifestyle that Muslims have practiced or
that the perception have been from non
Muslims concerning this ok the question
of perception is you you you have a
community that is distinct or different
and Muslims should just simply
concentrate on being if they're distinct
or different and being distinct or
different in a good way
which is what Muslims are supposed to do
supposed to make God central to the life
and take care of the fellow
and as long as they practice that
they're fine chuckling thank you very
much and that is it for now we're gonna
take a break and we're gonna be back
with more here live the Dean show in
Texas y'all sit tight
and if we're gonna worship something I
figured I might as well worship the
Creator instead of any of the creations
now in upon investigating the villages
on member finding out the meaning of
what Islam is what Muslim is those who
surrender their self to God is a Muslim
those who cemento submit to God God's
will die see Islam was pure it was just
you just pray to God your Creator
back here on a Dean show live in Texas
and we're here with David the author of
the last Christian we have a few more
minutes before the show comes to us and
and I have just a few more points I want
to cover it did you get a chance to
watch these Senate hearings with the
Pepe King Peter King only for a few
minutes
yeah I really didn't get to watch that
much of it they were coming together
discussing the radicalization of youth
so basically when you see some of the
politicians who are really supposed to
be working to create understanding you
know between the people bringing people
together but we really want the
politicians and people out there to
understand us better because maybe they
have good intentions but they they're
missing misunderstanding us okay here's
here's what I or that I would say yeah
the question is about whether Muslims
are or not good citizens the
Constitution defines what a good citizen
is and the preamble it says we the
people of the United States in order to
form a more perfect union establish
justice ensure domestic tranquility to
provide for the common defense to
promote the general welfare to secure
for our self-reports Terry the blessings
of liberties do establish and ordain
this constitution United States any
Muslim they can say that is a good
Muslim and most Muslims can say that
most Muslims will embrace it
most persons are good Americans that's
right I like that mashallah
so before we come to an end tell us now
where can people if they want to read
your book the last Christian we're going
to get this okay
simply remember the title last Christian
go online you can go to either
amazon.com or Barnes and Noble the
people who actually publish this book
are author house like I'm the author and
I live in a house authorHouse go online
they sell the book as well they also
sell it as an e-book hopefully a Texas
company Texas Global traders will also
soon be selling the book but remember my
name David Guillen and the title les
Christian and you can simply buy it
online it'd be the quickest easiest way
to do it I'd like to thank you and any
closing comments for those who are out
there
and the way of life that they're living
they're not happy with it it's confusing
and and they want to step out of the
confusion and they're just a little bit
timid you know culture class sometimes
they see Muslims as people who they just
can't identify with but they can
identify with Islam what advice do you
have for Islam if it's practice the way
it's supposed to be means peace it also
means the best form of life in others if
a person makes God the center of their
life and by doing so they take care of
their fellow human being they make the
world a better place and that is what
Islam is all about thank you very much
thank you very much may God Almighty the
creator reward you for being with us
thank you so much
and thank you again for tuning in to
another episode of the Deen show you
might not like spicy food neither do I
you might not like dress in a certain
way you like dressing your way as long
as this is a modest way don't worry
about it you can do it in Islam it's all
good as long as it's pleasing to the
creator of the heavens and the earth and
you see as you heard our guests say
making God the central point in your
life just worshiping God not worshiping
Jesus not worshiping statues icons idols
monkeys elephants none of these things
only worshipping the Creator and doing
good doing good to your neighbor doing
good to your parents doing good to your
fellow brothers and sisters in humanity
this is what Islam is about and you met
an American you met an American we've
interviewed Romanians Hispanics Islam is
the fastest growing way of life in the
world and thank you for coming to the
source to learn about the most
misunderstood yet fastest growing way of
life in the world Islam practiced by
over 1.5 billion and you could be a
Muslim too you can be a Muslim too
because a Muslim is simply one who takes
that free choice that they have of
either submitting to the creation of God
or submitting to God and you know what
the right thing to do is submit to the
one Jesus submitted to that's the one
God the one creator and do good deeds do
righteousness and this is what Islam is
calling you to get a free copy of the
Koran call the number on the screen 1
800 662 Islam read the verbatim Word of
God and continue to come back here to
the Deen show
till next time we started with people we
end with peace peace be unto you
see what everyone's talking about if you
find one contradiction it can't be from
God but the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best to give
up for spring guidance I will never give
up spreading this message okay you take
that necessary step you don't know if
you're gonna live till tomorrow so you
got to find that urges you to do the
right thing right now do not believe in
Jesus you have stepped outside of this
man you can not be a Muslim in attending
our faith too it's cold
Italy everybody sleeping I arise and ask
a lot of thinking me Omar you see all
our you know all the sins I do I turn to
you to forgive my sing tomorrow
well of whom will our collimator - a
hyena how horrid I mean her harbour well
Hajin I mean her happens I mean who you
who know what your Navi Hodja
meaning of you I don't wanna feel I mean
a little you neo me somebody what my me
that's why II D a fella
so the Hannity upon upon us what you
call me madam be to love me
b2 logo I mean uh who see mommy
moon why I love holiness no home anymore
now I faith Ali
on question suited Irina Mostafavi la da
de kaddipudi rollers easy lady
quano Pomeroy pas de una Humana's illa
hot the can road O'Neal padeen let some
samba villa ha
- d'eryka lupa marijuana a loser before
cool
beefing against Mahone
Oh